lo dejaron todo la familia de remedios
armas pérez tuvo que vivir de su hogar
con el anuncio del avance de la lava del
volcán cumbre vieja pero ahora mismo no
sé dónde están minadas adicionados a
todos por la tele se ve un amasijo negro
yo no imagino que no sabré ubicar
físicamente
como ella más de 6000 personas fueron
evacuadas de la palma ese es también el
caso de jose alejandro santos quien
perdió su casa y gran parte de sus
pertenencias ahora vive en una caravana
como su hogar temporal al igual que sus
padres y los niños de la familia que son
albergados en pequeñas habitaciones o en
casas de familias y conocidos la
caravana hace seis meses que la
compremos y gracias gracias a esto
o pueda escapar porque estamos
prácticamente en la calle en la calle
mal mal vídeos mal bañados mal comido
muchos no han podido encontrar vivienda
han a jessica costa relata que toparse
que un alquiler asequible ha sido un
calvario no quiero que me regalen una
casa ahora mismo ni que me quemé
hospeden gratis sino un alquiler que yo
pueda pagar porque mi marido es
pensionista cobra 600 euros he llamado a
500 mil me piden 800 600 los expertos
advierten que la erupción no está
estabilizada por lo que el volcán podría
seguir incrementando o disminuyendo su
actividad por lo que podría haber más
damnificados